[Musique]
je suis même pas malade j'ai pas de
souci particulier juste un peu de
fatigue quoi mais sinon en règle
générale ça va c'est juste les à côtés
quoi qu'ils sont plus à difficile parce
que mr en confinement ça c'est plus
simple plus difficiles comme je suis pas
immunisés contre la toxoplasmose et donc
je dois faire tous les mois c'est prise
de sang et les tests urinaires et ne
serait ce que pour prendre un rendez
vous sur montigny
tout ça c'est assez difficile des fois
je passe un sacré moment au téléphone
essayer de décrocher enfin ne serait-ce
qu il décroche
mais ça va j'ai la dernière fois j'ai
trouvé une du côté de la gare de
montigny samedi matin aux premières
heures j'étais très contente donc non
c'est mais c'est vraiment pas facile
quoi le parce que ce qui est normal les
gens se ruent sur les laboratoires pour
les tests tout ça donc bah c'est un peu
embouteillée quoi
mon compagnon ne peut pas venir peut pas
venir avec moi parce que ben a dû à la
pandémie
en fait est que la maman qui est
autorisé donc c'est un peu plus
difficile parce que bas comme monsieur a
pas pu venir bas pour l'échographie on a
su le sexe de l'enfant
c'est pas simple même si monsieur peut
pas être tout le temps avec moi ou aux
échographies ou quoi que ce soit il
participe aussi parce qu'on a une
application en fait sur le téléphone ou
dès qu'on a fini le rendez-vous en fait
toutes les toutes les photos elles sont
disponibles sur l'appli donc monsieur
peut voir à tout moment que tout cela
soit un lointain souvenir qu'on puisse
profiter du bébé a tranquillement avec
toute la famille
non franchement mais jouer moi
personnellement je suis quelqu'un
d'optimiste alors donc moi pour moi il
va y avoir que du bon de toute façon il
y aura que du bon mois le bébé va
arriver donc hélas c'est quelque chose
de magnifique et puis voilà